So I thought today in honor of Flora and Ulysses
on Disney plus, yeah I would help you figure out ways
to craft with food for your kids which is so much fun.
So I thought we'd make this little squirrel snack
not for squirrels but it's shaped like a squirrel.
Well teach me, teach me
where do we start so I can be like you
and my girls would love, we bake so much.
Yes
I've made every muffin and cake and bread on the planet
this is so much more inventive teach me.
Yes okay so let's start with the squirrel,
you'll take two grapes ,I sort of go for the big one
and then like a little one that's going to be the head
and then you just poke a toothpick through the bottom
of the big thing obviously you will tell your kids
there's a toothpick in it so they don't just bite into it.
And then leave a little nabbing out
cause that will help you stand it up later,
exactly.
And then you should have some mini chocolate chips,
I do
I'll start with the ears, so that will be ears,
so chocolate icing for a little glue
so you just dab a little, you know chocolate icing and
then put the ear.
I've got food tweezers cause I am obsessed,
put it sort of back on the top of the little grape
but sort of on the top and then the next one
kind of close to that one because
I feel like squirrel ears are close together.
Okay so then I think next
we should move on to the little candy eyes,
do you have those?
I do, I do
Now because I get obsessed like I said
I use white icing for this.
Oh, you know what that makes total sense--
If you don't have it that's fine just do the chocolate
it doesn't matter, so now put those not actually that far
away from the ears because I have tried them on the side
and they looked really like a possessed squirrel.
Yours is so good okay great,
so now I also liked using a mini chocolate chip as the nose
okay and so then you take the bigger chocolate chip
not the giant one and make little arms
think on the side and then I do two in the front
of the big grape as legs.
I really feel the facial expression that I've concocted.
Its all about the eyes.
I am very endeared these eyes are amazing,
where do you procure food eyes.
I mean everywhere Michaels sells a bunch of them.
Oh yeah.
You can definitely get them on Amazon, I feel like--
Look at him
he looks like he is on Johnny Carson right now.
No ,I love him so we've sat that down
and put him on the side for a second.
So you'll take your little,
It's like a ho ho or a ding dong
I don't know what it is but I want it so badly.
(laughing)
So in the south, I grew up with this brand
cause I am from Atlanta
but you just cut one of this in half or in thirds
and then you will have two and then I will put icing
in the middle of them to glue this two together
this is going to represent the little log
that the squirrel is going to sit on
but it needs to be wide so that,so the tail will fit.
And then you can stick your little squirrel without the tail
into the like one side of it.
Okay two logs, oh,
Yes like that
He's sitting on a log.
It's going to sit on a log
and the second log is going to help hold his tail in place
cause his tail is quite heavy.
Okay so now do you have the pre made cereal treat with
marshmallow cereal treat.
I do right here.
So the best way that I found
is to stick a toothpick into what will touch the squirrels
body so it's sort of the yes.
And then I also just for security do small chocolate icing
cause who doesn't like chocolate icing? What.
I mean I just want to put my face in all of this
is that wrong?
And then you just put that into your little squirrel
I forgot to shorten my toothpick so he is being impaled.
So normally I would cut that with a scissor
and then even easier take your big chocolate chip
and your little small cookie
and then just dab a little chocolate on the thing
either one and then cross it down
and put a little mini chocolate chip on top
and ta dah!
You have an acorn for the squirrels feet.
Oh.
And then to be healthy I added a strawberry mushroom
on top of that you know cause with grapes and strawberries
it's a healthy treat right.
This so awesome Alyson I love this.
Wow. I love it I think your kids
are going to be really happy.
I am definitely going to go home
and do this with them tonight
so thank you for that.
I am also going to have them watch Flora and Ulysses
with me tonight cause I got to watch it this weekend
for research.
And it really kind of like circles back
to our original conversation which is,
when are you a grown up when are you a kid.
Like all of this little messages that we are supposed
to grow up and flourish with as human beings.i just felt--
And a message of hope I love so much we this story too
of like we have to have hope and sort of
in the darkest times of our lives that's when you need it
the most and it's also the hardest to find
so that really resonated with me as well.
I just think this is a perfect movie for a family too
because the kids are going to love it,
the adults are going to love it
and that's what we need right now ,
more time together on the couch.
(laughing)
Really with snacks.
Be sure to watch Flora and Ulysses with your family
it's available now on Disney plus.
(upbeat music)